Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Denise RQ
Il nostro pianeta si è formato
circa 4 miliardi e mezzo di anni fa
e dopo meno di un miliardo
di anni è apparsa la vita,
all'inizio in forme estremamente semplici
e poi, via via, in forme
sempre più complesse
potete immaginare i dinosauri
che c'erano circa 200 milioni di anni fa.
Ma il punto più importante
nella nostra evoluzione
è stato 8 milioni di anni fa,
quando le scimmie antropomorfe
quindi quelle scimmie
che hanno sembianze umanoidi,
si sono separate evolutivamente
dagli ominidi che poi hanno portato
allo sviluppo dell'uomo.
Il manuale e il libretto delle istruzioni
attraverso il quale
tutti gli organismi viventi
dal più piccolino, i virus,
all'uomo, con i suoi 46 volumi,
questo manuale dell'istruzione è scritto
con un linguaggio molto semplice,
un linguaggio formato
da solo quattro lettere
- quindi pensate all'Alfabeto Morse
o una cosa simile -
che è condiviso quindi
tra tutti gli organismi viventi
e definisce le informazioni
quindi definisce le istruzioni
di quello che siamo, e di come siamo,
che da genetisti chiamiamo
queste istruzioni geni.
E queste istruzioni sono chiaramente
cambiate nel corso dell'evoluzione,
perché siamo passati da organismi
molto semplici come virus
a organismi complessi come l'uomo,
e questi cambiamenti
però a volte possono essere
anche limitati a una sola lettera.
Que come vedete può per esempio
già farci cambiare colore dei capelli,
ma una sola lettura può avere
anche delle conseguenze
molto negative per la nostra salute
perché può essere responsabile
della predisposizione a numerose malattie.
Alle mie spalle ne vedete alcune,
ma noi oggi contiamo
almeno 5000 malattie a base genetica
dove una sola lettera
è sufficiente a determinare
la predisposizione alla malattia
ma queste probabilmente sono
molte di più, saranno circa 10.000.
Ora, queste variazioni, però sono state
fondamentali nella nostra evoluzione
perché hanno permesso di passare appunto
da un organismo molto semplice
a un organismo molto complesso,
quindi questi sono esperimenti
che madrenatura ha sempre fatto
e che hanno portato
molte volte a degli errori,
che poi sono pian pianino
stati eliminati nel processo evolutivo,
altre volte invece
hanno portato ad evolvere
quello che noi siamo diventati,
Homo Sapiens Sapiens.
Nel caso dell'uomo, per esempio,
i primi diciamo esperimenti di madrenatura
sull'Homo vero e proprio sono stati fatti
a partire da 2 milioni e mezzo
di anni fa con l'Homo Habilis
che aveva un volume
della scatola cranica di 0,6 litri
- noi abbiamo una scatola
cranica che è di 1,4 litri -
quindi guardate come col passare del tempo
questa scatola cranica si è allargata
per permetterci di essere sempre
più capaci di gestire quello che siamo.
Habilis aveva solo la capacità
di riuscire a costruire
qualche arnese estremamente semplice.
E' solo col passare del progetto
evolutivo verso l'Homo Sapiens
che invece siamo riusciti a sviluppare,
anche una coscienza
di quello che noi siamo
e siamo riusciti a diventare
quello che siamo oggi.
Ora, il viaggio del Sapiens
è un viaggio molto interessante,
perché l'Homo, la culla di sviluppo
evolutivo dell'Homo è in Africa.
Da lì ci sono state diverse uscite
verso il resto del mondo,
Sapiens che è quello
che poi ha colonizzato il pianeta
anche se per un certo periodo
di tempo ha condiviso, almeno in Europa,
il suo percorso insieme a Neanderthal,
che è scomparso 30 mila anni fa,
Sapiens è uscito dall'Africa
almeno tre volte: 100.000 anni fa,
poi 80 mila anni fa ha raggiunto l'Asia,
ma il momento in cui è uscito
in modo prepotente
ed è riuscito a camminare,
a raggiungere tutte le zone del pianeta
è stato circa 60 mila anni fa:
ma se guardate i periodi
in cui per esempio
noi abbiamo raggiunto
il continente americano
vedete che questo è un periodo
di tempo estremamente ridotto
nei confronti della vita
di questo nostro pianeta,
è un battito d'ali di una farfalla,
sono pochi istanti in una vita
che è lunghissima: 4 miliardi e mezzo.
Allora in questo viaggio,
noi abbiamo imparato ad evolvere,
abbiamo imparato anche che esiste
una grande competizione
a livello di altre specie
per condividere le risposte
di questo pianeta
e così, come tutti gli altri organismi,
siamo stati limitati,
come numerosità, soprattutto dal ridotto
approvvigionamento alimentare.
Fino a quando l'uomo è stato nomade
si è dovuto nutrire di quello
che madrenatura aveva prodotto
ed e'stato soltanto quando ha cominciato
ad addomesticare le specie
- quindi circa 5-10 mila anni fa
che la disponibilità di cibo aumentata
ha permesso al Sapiens di riuscire
a crescere come numerosità.
E questo l'ha fatto in modo progressivo,
fino a circa al 1300-1350
quando -vedete- il picco in caduta,
che è dovuto alla peste bubbonica,
che ha sterminato tra i 20
e 25 milioni di persone in Europa,
che equivalgono a un terzo
della popolazione europea,
equivalgono alla metà
della popolazione italiana dell'epoca.
Quindi in quel momento in Europa
c'era la popolazione che oggi troviamo
più o meno nel nostro paese.
E poi vedete questo picco drammatico
- da un certo punto di vista
visto almeno con gli occhi
di madrenatura spaventoso -
di crescita della popolazione:
eravamo un miliardo nel 1800,
eravamo due miliardi nel 1930,
e da quel momento in poi aumentiamo
di un miliardo ogni 10-15 anni;
e non c'è termine
non c'è fine a questa crescita,
almeno per i prossimi 30 o 40 anni
per cui continueremo a crescere
ed invadere questo pianeta.
questo perché? perché da un lato
abbiamo nell'ultimo secolo soprattutto,
cambiato il modo di alimentarci,
abbiamo nuove varietà a disposizione.
vedete alla mia estrema destra
una spiga di Teosinte
che è il progenitore del mais
quindi immaginate di dovervi nutrire
con i chicchi che stanno ç
in quella spiga che ha piena maturità
e confrontatevela con una spiga
di mais che appena più alla mia sinistra
che invece ha una dimensione spaventosa;
spaventosa almeno vista
con gli occhi di madrenatura
che mai si sarebbe sognato
di fare una cosa così.
Ma l'uomo in questo caso è intervenuto
e ha costruito qualcosa
che va contro le leggi della natura
ma che va a favore
di quelle che sono le leggi dell'uomo.
E poi, l'altra ragione
per cui siamo cresciuti così tanto
è lo sviluppo della medicina
e naturalmente della farmacologia
quindi la capacità di adattare l'ambiente
e di superare quelli che sono
i nostri limiti genetici
intervenendo con la chimica
e con l'impiego di altre sostanze.
Questo fa sì che oggi noi sì,
viviamo più a lungo
ma di fatto siamo meno sani
perché viene a mancare
quella che noi genetisti chiamiamo
'selezione purificatrice'
Che fa sì che persone, individui
che hanno determinate malattie genetiche
e che hanno determinate predisposizioni
ad alcune suscettibilità varie,
per esempio peste bubbonica,
muoiano e quindi in questo modo
Madre Natura impedisce che questi geni,
queste istruzioni che non sono positive
almeno per lo sviluppo della specie
non vengano più trasferiti.
Invece cosa è successo, per esempio,
nel caso della peste bubbonica?
Tutte le persone resistenti,
quelle che sono sopravvissute,
si sono moltiplicate
hanno generato dei figli
e i figli erano automaticamente resistenti
per cui portavano nel loro patrimonio
genetico queste caratteristiche positive.
Coloro che erano suscettibili
alla malattia invece sono morti,
non hanno più procreato,
per cui c'è stata quella che appunto
madrenatura definisce
una 'selezione purificatrice'.
Ora immaginate che cosa
succederebbe in questo momento
se noi applicassimo
una cosa come questa oggi.
Ebola è un esempio molto,
secondo me, molto bello da fare.
Secondo madrenatura noi oggi
dovremmo essere praticamente
sterminati da Ebola
nelle ultime due settimane
abbiamo scoperto
che anche la resistenza Ebola
ha una base genetica
adesso stiamo lavorando
alla velocità della luce
quindi in piena sintonia con quello
che è l'argomento della giornata
e poco più di dieci giorni fa è stato
scoperto, su alcuni modelli di topi,
che è possibile avere
dei topi ipersensibili a Ebola
ma è anche possibile
avere dei topi resistenti,
completamente resistenti al virus,
per cui c'è una base genetica
che ci permette di resistere
per cui sicuramente se non ci curassimo
una parte della popolazione mondiale
sarebbe destinata a scomparire
perché infettata da questo virus
ma una parte resisterebbe.
Quindi secondo madrenatura
noi oggi dovremmo arrivare
a procreare solo e soltanto
se fossimo resistenti a questo virus
che invece noi sconfiggiamo
con l'impiego dei vaccini
che abbiamo messo appunto
alla velocità anche in questo caso
una velocità spaventosamente elevata
che ha permesso appunto
già di salvare le prime vite umane oggi.
Ora visto che noi conosciamo
quali sono ormai
le basi genetiche di numerose malattie,
possiamo anche cercare grazie
allo sviluppo tecnologico
che c'è stato negli ultimi anni
di leggere i nostri genomi e vedere
direttamente che cosa ci sta scritto
per cercare di prevenire quelle che sono
le eventuali predisposizioni
che noi portiamo.
Io sono genetista quindi quando
ho avuto la possibilità
di cominciare a decodificare
e a sequenziare i genomi umani
- il primo genoma che ho voluto
sequenziare è stato il mio -
non per vanità,ma perché volevo cercare
da genetista per primo di capire
la difficoltà che un essere umano ha
nel leggere scritto magari
nel proprio genoma
di avere predisposizione
per una malattia grave.
E devo dire che questo
è stato un percorso molto lungo:
io comincio a parlare di questa mia
esperienza solo quest'anno,
nonostante il mio genoma mi sia
disponibile ormai da tre anni.
Mi sono sequenziato, mi sono interpretato,
quello che vedete è una
rappresentazione dei miei cromosomi,
con dei pallini arancioni
che corrispondono
a delle posizioni che portano
delle predisposizioni
diciamo in qualche maniera interessanti,
e io ve ne mostrerò un paio.
La prima che vi mostro è questa:
è una predisposizione
alla Sindrome del QT lungo,
ovvero della morte improvvisa.
Io ho un difetto genetico,
in un canale del potassio
che serve per polarizzare il cuore.
Immaginate il battito cardiaco
abbiamo una scarica elettrica
che porta a una depolarizzazione
delle cellule del miocardio
che poi si devono ricaricare.
L'esempio più bello da fare, forse,
è quello di un flash di una volta
molti di voi sono così giovani
da non ricordare
ma le persone della mia età ricordano
i flash quando avevano la lucina rossa,
e doveva, questa lucina doveva accendersi
prima di poter scattare la fotografia
perché avremmo avuto un lampo di luce
ma poi dovevamo aspettare
un certo periodo di tempo
che le batterie ricaricassero
questo flash,
e se noi cercavamo di scattare la foto
prima che la batteria fosse stata
completamente ricaricata
il flash andava a vuoto.
Il mio cuore fa lo stesso:
quando parte il comando,
se il cuore è stato ricaricato
a sufficienza il battito avviene
se il cuore non è ancora stato ricaricato
il battito non avviene
e il sistema va in cortocircuito,
la persona collassa, morte improvvisa
a meno che non sia disponibile
nelle vicinanze un defibrillatore.
Casi come questi accadono
per fortuna raramente,
ma ogni tanto sentiamo parlare
di calciatori o sportivi
che improvvisamente collassano,
appunto per questa sindrome che è legata
a una singola base che è cambiata,
come potete vedere lì.
Allora io ho chiesto, quando la genetica
mi ha detto di avere
questa predisposizione
io ho chiesto alla clinica di confermare
che davvero il dato genetico
potesse essere confermato,
anche solo da un elettrocardiogramma.
Io partivo dalla lettura
di un'istruzione genetica
che per me era difettosa e che implicava
una determinata caratteristica
negativa per il mio cuore.
Ho chiesto di fare l'elettrocardiogramma
e che vedete è il valore del mio QT.
Il medico che mi ha, il cardiologo
che mi ha sottoposto all'esame
mi ha detto i maschi hanno
un Qt generalmente di 440,
le femmine di 460.
Questo Qt, che è questo ritardo
nella riaccensione del flash
viene considerato comunque
accettabile fino a 480:
sopra ai 480 la persona
è a rischio di morte improvvisa.
Io sono a 504,
per cui secondo questo medico
io dovrei girare
col defibrillatore di fianco a me
dovrei prendere beta-bloccanti
per tenere il battito regolare.
Io non lo faccio, non lo faccio
ma non perché sia folle
semplicemente perché guardando
la casistica nella mia famiglia
i miei genitori quando hanno saputo
di questa cosa
è stata una bellissima
discussione fatta con loro
perché ho detto
ho questa mutazione ho varianti
io l'ho presa da uno di voi.
Avendola presa da uno di voi,
uno di voi porta la mia stessa variante.
I miei genitori hanno più di 70 anni
hanno fatto a gara per risultare positivi,
ho analizzato entrambi,
non vi dico chi dei due ma uno
dei due miei genitori è positivo
e felicissimo perché dice,
sarebbe una morte bellissima.
Io continuo a dire
è più facile morire probabilmente
investito da un'automobile
che morire di morte improvvisa
però questa mutazione
ce l'ho e me la tengo.
Poi un'altra mutazione che ho
secondo me estremamente interessante
è una predisposizione genetica al malumore
e per alcuni autori
è anche una predisposizione
alla insoddisfazione matrimoniale
per cui mia moglie purtroppo è sfortunata
ho un difetto su un trasportatore
della serotonina.
la serotonina viene emessa da un neurone,
viene percepita nello spazio sinaptico
e poi però dev'essere
riportata nel neurone.
Funziona a impulsi:
quando il livello di serotonina
è normale, il nostro umore è normale;
se il livello di serotonina
è più basso del normale,
noi andiamo in depressione fino al punto
di arrivare ad avere istinti suicidi.
I farmaci, la maggior parte
dei farmaci antidepressivi
funzionano bloccando quei trasportatori
che riportano la serotonina dentro,
per cui tengono elevato il livello
di serotonina nello spazio sinaptico.
Ecco, io ho un problema: questi
miei trasportatori funzionano malissimo
per cui non risponderei
a un farmaco antidepressivo
basato appunto sull'inibizione di questi.
E cosa è successo?
Col passare del tempo
avendo dei livelli di serotonina
nello spazio sinaptico
più alti del normale
io ho desensibilizzato il mio sistema;
oggi per avere un umore normale
devo riuscire ad avere una scarica
di serotonina superiore al normale.
Questo lo posso fare in due modi:
nicotina che estrae
una extradose di serotonina
e io devo dire, purtroppo,
sono anni che cerco di smettere
di fumare e faccio veramente fatica;
e la seconda cosa, anfetamine.
A questo punto, mia moglie
si trova nelle condizioni di avere
o il marito depresso
oppure il marito drogato.
Non so che cosa possa scegliere
- immagino non sia contenta
in nessuna delle due soluzioni.
Ora, conoscendo però queste cose,
conoscendo quali sono
le basi genetiche delle nostre malattie,
noi possiamo pensare non solo
a noi stessi ma anche ai nostri figli,
e dicevo di questa selezione purificatrice
che fa sì che, morendo, individui che
portano predisposizioni genetiche gravi,
queste predisposizioni genetiche,
quindi queste istruzioni negative,
non vengano trasferite alla progenie,
perché la persona non è in grado
di avere figli, muore prima.
Ora, Gattaca, film di fantascienza
bellissimo del 97,
quindi poco meno di vent'anni, giusto?
che racconta la storia di una società
in cui gli individui sono
geneticamente perfetti,
perché gli embrioni vengono selezionati
e quindi questa selezione purificatrice
che Madre Natura faceva
portando alla morte degli individui
prima di arrivare alla procreazione,
in questo caso viene fatta
in modo artificiale
sulla base di parametri che sono
quelli che sono definiti dall'uomo.
Oggi questa non è più fantascienza:
lo facciamo in questo momento,
per quelle che sono malattie terribilmente
gravi, tipo la fibrosi cistica
quindi è possibile oggi,
anche per dei genitori
che portano il difetto genetico
di una malattia come questa,
riuscire a dar vita dei figli normali
mediante la selezione genetica
di quelli che sono gli embrioni.
Il problema che io vedo però è,
qual è il nostro limite?
Noi oggi siamo in grado
di operare delle scelte
che non sono più le scelte di madrenatura,
sono le scelte dell'uomo
che ci porteranno ad evolvere
verso una direzione che ancora
francamente non conosciamo.
Fino ad oggi, probabilmente,
abbiamo fatto sempre le scelte giuste,
speriamo di continuate a farne ancora.
Grazie.
(Applausi)